you dare enter this house
it's Friday [__] nothing but [__]
and elbows pilot to Bombardier pilot to
Bombardier
[Applause]
good googly moogly what's happening you
bad [__] Friday October 6 which
you against the world [__] you
follow me as usual uncle Joey here to
give you a little [__] weekend
encouragement both church episodes are
up Nick the door and Liam myself you got
a national anthem you gotta [__] this
bunch of [__] to deal with but besides
that I'm just here to let you
[__] know listen it was a rough
week for everybody in more ways than one
man it's Friday sit back with your
families appreciate the people around
you in your life and don't take nobody
for granted there's what happens when
people take people for [__] grant
I'll take nobody for granted there's
some people who deserve to get hit by a
[__] car but the people around you
your family don't take them for granted
ever you got three four people you could
take over a [__] world with them yo
may have lost my grandma this week like
my part-time grandma it was just one of
those [__] weeks but guess what
[__] that don't mean you're
gonna stop me I was at the store last
night [__] [__] and elbows
brother working I'm moving to the next
[__] goal right your [__] balls
you're 22 push-ups you never stopped the
dream never ends to you [__] knocking
on the door with your dick out saying
what Uncle Joe is here and the dream is
complete
Clemence DC more
it's a beautiful [__] day to be
alive the birds a champion the sun's out
the trees out everybody's [__] up
except you you sitting on a computer
looking and thinking what am I gonna do
with my life boy here's the [__]
answer grab your balls salute the flag
get up and go for your [__] dream cuz
it's a long life unless you're in love
with what the [__] you're doing and I'm
saying who gives a [__] what people tell
you don't like it you don't have to do
it it's your world [__] the rest
of us are just visiting and that's it
and that's that
don't forget today I got would you jet I
got a little writing but I got date
night with my beautiful wife you gotta
take care of family
then Sunday we're back Tuesday we're
back and then Thursday night I'll see
you [__] at the Tampa improv
[__] Miami [__] in Gainesville
Jacksonville listen this is my only
Florida appearance you know I love you
[__] but I'm spread out too
[__] thin but I want to see all you
savages in [__] Florida you follow me
go down there heat some [__] New
York's now food some Cuban food and I'm
back in three [__] days but I'm gonna
I'm gonna have a great time I can't wait
to go to [__] Tampa beside that I
accomplished my goals a little we dived
in my two podcasts I did my five spots
so far I've been to two jiu-jitsu tiny
one [__] more maybe two more so I'll
go today and Sunday for the week that's
four I worked out
I cried I laughed you know it was a
great [__] week man so and Wednesday
night's podcast you guys helped me more
than I you could ever [__] know like
when you guys come up to me at shows and
go Joey
you know the podcast help me get to
listen Wednesday night you guys got me
through a big [__] hurdle but hey
here we go we got a little [__]
chocolate fund again and we have to tell
them the [__] Skywalker after I do
this little taste Oktay with you
[__] headed over to the weave
store to pick up my shipment for the
[__] weekend yawns and you always got
to be tip-top Magoo no misunderstandings
the store opens up at 10:00 I walk in
that [__] 10:05 you follow me
cuz that's the way I do think the early
bird always gets the worm and has for
the last [__] two thousand years why
do you want to make it dinner laughs I
strolled out of better - who gives a
[__] you missed half the [__] day you
might as well go back to bed and put a
[__] gun in your mouth getting up at
2:00 nothing's gonna happen to the world
happens at 8:00 a.m. I fell asleep
before 5:00 [__] a clock wise I can't
fall asleep at all last night
I was up at 8:00 [__] who gives a
[__] I got [__] they're doing people who
see late in the afternoon I take a
little nap if-if-if not [__] it we go
straight
Oh mix me some tear the opportunity to
just be out here in the Sun in a
free-falling country talking to my
favorite [__] people in the world
smoking a ball you gotta ask yourself
who the [__] is better than us your
ashes of that [__] simple question
who's better than us we got a good as a
[__] family worth what Internet
family who's better than you nobody else
is a part of something like this nobody
else's got this we have family would
breathe for one another
I'm with you you're with me and they
wanna be with us that's it looking
around trying to [__] and stagger their
way we got it down over here you follow
me let's hit this [__] chocolate
whatever the [__] it is let's get you
stole no that's an old-school indica and
that [__] sky walk is no joke and that
[__] sunset whenever I'm hearing
things already I'm hearing a little bee
it's like I broke into a place and I'm
hearing the alarm but I didn't break
into the place it's like breaking into a
place without breaking into a place you
follow me
anyway let's fill this one up and at
least we post a day as a [__] family
and that's it well she's gonna get this
type of [__] action nobody else you
know why as I love you [__]
without you [__] I'd have nothing
and have you bats but some people don't
know that at least I was on it you
always gotta put the lid on weave in
cases an earthquake [__] the roof could
go down but you saved the weed that's
the most important thing so that's it
that's that you know I love your
[__] I wouldn't do this [__] if
I didn't love you [__] all right
but all my heart I want you to write
your goals now and I want you to go for
it who gives a [__] with these [__]
people say your [__] family it's all
about you as if you'd learn let's
pretend you get to be [__] 54 like me
let's pretend you don't live your dream
we're gonna be like you're gonna be
walking around yeah in that go for it
who gives a [__] what anybody thinks at
the end there there's you and that
[__] casket at the end with that
cheap [__] soda huh and no shoes on
don't tell nobody tell you what the [__]
to do you wake up today you feel like
[__] go for it this is your dream
this who the [__] you are this is who
defines you found or what defines you
that's what I should be say
that's it
unless that is how we do it 7:24 I gotta
know I've been out hit three times
before you [__] that's how I'd
do this I get down I'm making moves I
drove the baby to school now I'm here
tip top module ready for the [__]
take with the day as to offer I'm happy
but the [__] off me fly top sucker
that's one of these hummus flies eats
that hummus that [__] comes out of your
neck flies from all over the
neighborhood a [__] foul um anyway I
love you [__] without you I got
dick I'll see you savages Thursday night
had to pamper him progress hey listen
we'd [__] bring it all bulletproof
vest [__] [__] helmets I don't give
a [__]
we're going deep next weekend in Tampa
you understand me somebody's gonna get
fed to the Lions like that [__] dying
Goodfellas mother to them at Apple same
[__] difference
I'll see you wet guys with the church on
Sunday and Tuesday night and that's it
listen all you got to do today is be a
little bit better than when you were
yesterday and you [__] and then
Saturday you're a little bit better than
what you were Friday and listen it's
always gonna be a beautiful day to be
alive they didn't get my matter like
Bing ahoy
we'll get that wrong telecoil and a liar
well pcq left wrong color in Bali I love
your [__] always have a great
weekend keep your eyes open but the
[__] falling away with the stupidity
and watch the [__] door right I love
you have a great [__] weekend see you
Sunday